good morning Hank it's Tuesday and I'm
wearing a suit which can only mean one
thing it's time for the bank of nerd
feria's semiannual report so like a lot
of us the bank of nerd Feria has two
arms the goodstore dftba.com arm and the
project for awesome arm but today I will
argue that there might be a secret third
arm which does not involve the spending
or receiving of money and might be the
most important arm of them all but let's
start with good store so in 2019 our
community began supporting Partners in
Health in their efforts to radically red
prod maternal and child mortality in the
Kono District of Sierra Leon since then
a maternal and infant care center has
nearly been finished at kidu government
hospital I mean they're painting right
now some of the wards will open this
year and as part of this commitment we
were like we're going to need some
ongoing funding sources like long-term
ongoing and that's how the awesome socks
Club got started it's a subscription for
socks and since then we've launched good
dot store which has not only socks but
also excellent coffee and soap
subscriptions so in 2019 we were able to
to donate about
$268,000 across all our merch projects
and in 2020 we were able to donate
$598,000 for the year and it just kept
growing from there until there was a
huge jump last year and last year alone
we donated almost $3.5 million now
maintaining that growth is going to be
really challenging mostly because both
the company and nerd Feria received a
ton of media attention last year because
of a thing that just to be clear we do
not want to repeat but still these have
come quite successful businesses how
does the money break down well most of
it still comes from the awesome socks
Club but both coffee and soap are
growing and last year pus grew as well
and this is meant that we're able to
support not just the maternal and Child
Care Project in Sierra Leon but also
others like this year Hanks cancer socks
raised over
$350,000 to support better Cancer Care
in impoverished communities and we're
able to support increasing access to
tuberculosis care as well the whole idea
here when we started was that if we
worked with a team of really talented
people we could potentially raise more
money by starting these businesses than
we could ever donate on our own and
that's happened so that's one arm of the
bank of nerd Feria and then we have the
second arm which is the project for
awesome it's a completely separate
project since 2007 nerd Feria has
organized an annual charity Fest called
the project for awesome that has raised
about $12 million in total for charity
some of this goes to pre-selected
Charities usually Partners in Health and
save the children and then some of it
goes to Charities chosen by nerd Feria
through their votes on project for
awesome videos at projectforawesome.com
it's really wonderful it is my favorite
time of the year to be a nerd fighter
this year we already have $100,000 in
the bank from people who've donated
throughout the year and we've started to
build a matching fund which is now at
$227,000 which is incredible but we want
to grow it even more so that every small
donor to the project for awesome can get
their donation matched by someone who
can donate over $500 so if you're such a
person who can donate over $500 to this
year's project for awesome there is a
link in the dubly Doo and in the pinned
comment below to go let us know about
you and yes your donations are tax
deductible because we have a real
charity called the foundation to
decrease World suck which sounds like
it's not a real charity but it is and
then there is the secret third arm of
the bank of nerd Feria whose power was
really Unleashed in the last year and
which doesn't involve the spending or
donating of any money I'm talking about
advocacy so in 2023 our community helped
convince the corporation Johnson and
Johnson to abandon all secondary patents
on the critical tuberculosis drug
baceline and that's already resulted in
lower prices making baceline more
accessible in the communities where it's
most needed TB fighters in our community
also pressured the conglomerate danaher
to lower the price of their critically
important tuberculosis tests an effort
which is ongoing but has already
resulted in a price reduction for the
standard tuberculosis test test and a
pledge from danur not to profit from
that test in impoverished communities
now there's still a long way to go in
these advocacy efforts and just to State
the obvious we are not the only or even
the primary driver behind them but we
have played a really important role the
global fund recently estimated that the
danaher price reduction alone will
result in a $32 million savings over the
next 3 years allowing Millions more
people to get accurate fast tuberculosis
tests and of course not all of that
savings is attributable to nerd Feria
Partners in Health and Doctors Without
Borders and the treatment Action Group
and so many TB survivors have been
working for these changes for years but
let's say our stake in that change was
20% that would mean that advocacy
created a bigger Financial win for
Global Health Equity than good store and
the project for awesome combined and
that's a reminder to me that how we
spend our money isn't the only thing
that matters although of course it does
matter very much how we spend our time
and our attention also matters and
because so many people in nerd Feria
have gotten involved in advocacy for
those living with tuberculosis changes
that we could never have bought or sold
have nonetheless become possible so when
we say regardless of whether you want to
buy awesome socks or can donate to the
project for awesome thank you for being
part of this we mean it we really really
mean it Hank I'll see you on Friday $32
million in savings from the danaher
thing
wow